welcome to this video playing step by
step again the sky and play a number of
times just five times it feels like more
and he's playing quickly this is some
pretty evident night each form here not
not sure what this played against that
more
okay not sure that the night is so great
on h4 really is trying to make some
sense out of this I guess the night
position um I just play playing normal
way I e65 ok yeah this now looks a bit
like a queen's gambit accepted with this
move Bishop t2 Bishop to e2 this is not
like one of the most ambitious way two
ways to set up in the Q GA for white not
there are some points probably I think I
thought maybe he could take and Iowa it
didn't didn't happen okay um if I take
here and get to the IQ p.m. house is
playing a quick Bishop f3 my light
squares could could be a problem I can
also just take off cosplay 97 okay
that's a go for that I'm behind in
development this is really am a possible
problem the structure is very nice but
the development is not maybe I had no
tech see 5 her no not without canceling
okay um he probably will play nighty for
trying to go to d6 so very likely
actually
not sure how to set set up the pieces
came rook the aid listen repudiate
covering d7 and preparing to fight for
always playing as something entirely
different okay I thought 94 there was
the whole point Jack this zone I don't
mind at all maybe I'm seeing it I'm
misjudging it but yeah well this is just
I'm not sure that this leads to much I
can just take it next move on till here
takes Knight X I've got 93 le4 I don't I
don't really think is good the night now
on c3 has nowhere to go I think 94 was
better I'm just trying to make sense out
of it with it with an exchange sec so
what's some in some way to be expected
it's not the type of person who wants to
retreat stuff this is this I gathered
from further games um okay I'll take it
and now a that's 95 this is white white
has some compensation that sir that's
quite clear and wonder should I play you
five mammoth this relative sup t5
maybe I need any counter play I need
counterclaim attacking be 26 now you
know ok at least I where we are
approaching this point where where he
needs to meet me or something he now I
also want the spawn but what white still
has compensation quite quite clearly ok
well I think f6 may be awesome still
download time it didn't feel to me like
I was playing us so slowly but ok he's
playing very quickly ok take him I was
six is saying about f5s ok maybe maybe
keeping it closed I'm not sure now its
position is quite surely winning for
black but it still needs to be played
with the centimeter time
oops I didn't even see that this wasn't
this wasn't intended there's some
returning the porn absolutely not time
warning
I want I want a passed pawn myself
and okay well as left 50-something
second so this is not so bad sure yeah I
guess 94 yes it's it's a bit of a
problem mmm really is okay not this was
not intended of course
I need I need counter play with Luke a 3
check now so it's a draw now but I've
got eight seconds and he's not I do not
not the type of person gives up a draw
maybe I can get one of the satellite one
of the pieces of to secure the draw yeah
but this should be should be possible
really check check Jeff King drama he
would have played on time that's clear
um ok chalo ok this was certainly
winning for black but not not easy to do
maybe around here I really should should
manage but white has this paw only six
of course it's not like it's it's it's
it's it's it's an easy win or something
at least i don't i don't see it i mean
this this is a risky business or what i
try to win h4 h4 computer says this is
winning ok maybe ok there are the little
things I thought this but this rook see
for now and this is tying him up very
nicely I am that that sets a problem
what is some White's meals now here or
I've got this one
+ h2 yeah well this is the kind of stuff
you can find with them with enough time
but so it's tricky to do and around here
it's okay i ran into this 94 stuff which
costs also lots of time but you're still
h3 should be good for me according to
the computer hmm really it feels very
risky very risky I take here Brooks you
three winning okay probably promoting
the pawn okay yeah well that's all very
very tough to do I thought I need some
counter play around here I'm probably
probably losing but he also was just
trying to win on time not caring about
good moose anymore and here I think it's
a chat really can hear hear it's a draw
I mean also I will manage to to
sacrifice the rook to really secure the
technical draw with the knob with no
material left to really make it a draw
him all right interesting game thanks
for watching